In respect of many of these
technological projects of mortality,
what survives is not the person who
wants lived
in,
um,
a coach wiles version as I understand
it.
Uh,
what is proposed is that elements of the
conscious mind,
the conscious self of the people
concerned are somehow a programmed
computed and then projected into
cyberspace where that self aware,
um,
mind can create a variety of bodies for
itself in a virtual environment.
So rather than having the one frail
aging vulnerable,
a body that we,
each of us have to start with,
uh,
people can have a whole variety of
different bodies,
different genders when they get bored
with them or want to change them for
other reasons,
they can have as many as they want.
My objection is that what would have,
I would not be the person because first
of all,
it would only be the parts of the person
which are conscious and can be
programmed.
And my view is that,
um,
the larger part of each of us and a
large part of where our creativity,
uh,
in,
in our lives,
comes from both artistic and
intellectual.
Creativity is not conscious.
It's in a,
it's,
it's in part of ourselves,
which is not accessible to conscious
awareness.
So if I'm a,
um,
my conscious life,
my conscious intellectual life is
somehow had coded and encrypted and then
projected into a virtual afterlife,
what the will be out there will be a
sort of thinned out cartoon of the
person,
a thinned out image of the,
of the whole person I once was,
and I'm not interested in that kind of
immortality.
I wouldn't accept it if I were offered,
offered it.
Um,
I might very well except an extension of
long get of healthy longevity of the
kind that Aubrey degrade talks about.
Um,
we're already living longer and
healthier than many previous human
generations did.
I see nothing inherently wrong with
that,
but indefinite longevity is not
immortality and it's not the kind of
radical freedom from bodily frailty that
future as such as Kurtzweil want.